[Music]
yeah we rolling let's talk to the people
no drums no no you know now what's
happening Hannibal Burres hey I'm Tony
true what was I'm just me
I was concerned with your mic stand look
like it's about to fall off the table
man I see this and I'm good it's not see
that's what's wrong with people feel
like I got this
so yeah man I'm living life differently
now yeah
going into the 2019 can you explain to
the to the fans what's going on here
well I started I started sleeping with a
sleep mask and it was helping it helped
my quality of sleep no I felt great in
the mornings this is three three nights
in a row sleep my sleep woke up feeling
fresh usually with a sleep as well yeah
a couple of times I used it for
psychedelic reasons too long yeah it's
fun but no sleep though yeah me voice
practice sometimes not sometimes like
I've done it a couple of times it's like
using earplugs is great man I felt I
felt I felt powerful when I woke up in
the morning with just off of sleep alone
usually when I wake up I don't feel
powerful until I play some Oh Redman
songs then I feel powerful
Oh some old jazz but to sleep this is
quality sleep and then I got into the
sleep mask world started googling the
benefits of sleep masks and I was saying
what if I've been doing it got upset
damn it if I was getting quality sleep
my sleep
for all of my 20s I have $100,000,000 by
now I blame it on the quality of my
sleep but it's not too late
bounce back so I tried to extend it
further just to see this is okay sleep
mass help you while you sleep well I
want to keep this going how sleep mass
help you
when you awake too so I just started
going around the house or sleep mask on
doing my chores walking a dog grabbing a
mail drive it just to check just to test
the limits of my abilities sharpen up my
other abilities you know doing doing
text text by voice voice text not you
have to be so hey Siri was Greg in
message Kelvin Stovall huh never mind
so yeah I just been rolling with the
mask on for the past I want some change
and it's and it's uh changed my life for
the better you should try it with like
earplugs - then you get the whole
experience that's but then what what
trying to do the the Helen Keller
experience and what I'm just sitting in
a room knit no I still want to live life
I don't want it not here no that's all
touch you have to just touch everything
I smell smell touch and think what then
I'm not even am I even dealing with
other human beings what am i doing
it's the Helen Keller experience no man
no all right no Ivan added suggestion
yeah that's crazy
rocket asleep have ain't crazy
no no why not just go all the way man
that's that all the way cuz then I can't
hear didn't what I'm supposed to Alan's
will to listen to jazz you make the
chasm no jazz in your jazz is in your in
your in your rhythm no I walk listen doc
don't see this is what happens when when
you try to I've seen this happen time
and time again and I've seen it in the
movies when you try to progress in your
life people don't accept your progress
they try to diminish it and say well you
ain't been blind and deaf let me just I
I had a theory since I've been hearing
impaired not hear and visually impaired
Lee in prayer I think I'm actually a
slight not hearing impaired but my
hearing is diminishing cuz of years of
nightlife and being close to speakers
and black like but on the bright side I
think by the time I need hearing aids
they
really dope they're already pretty
doping and kind of low-key but do you
ever watch shows and [ __ ] with the
closed captioning on when they get
accents oh yeah yeah when you're
watching like peaky blinders or
something it's something on yes I'm sure
they have a yeah yeah
thick accent sometimes it could be a
regular show with American accents and
I'll just if you over if I was at a
house and then they're being be they had
closed caption on and sometimes I just
leave it on and realize it's not taking
much away from the experience you know
yeah okay it's not I do it all the time
because I like to watch I like to watch
stuff on cooking so when that when that
when that skillet starts sizzling I
can't hear no more but I don't see so I
have the closed caption on for that yeah
that's how I used to be when I was we
cooking that dope every cooking a dope
and cooking a dope and I couldn't hear
jeopardy no more while I'm cooking a
dope the dough starts sizzling the pot
over boil then all the crack spill into
my potted soil damn I plant oh here's
what I was thinking about what's up I
want to do experiment yeah potted plants
two potted plants over time mm-hmm
one that I water and treat how the books
say you supposed to water and treat a
plant and the other one I just pee in
and see how they grow well the one you
peeing is gonna die all the ammonia from
your piss buddy but I did more times and
I still your boss listen I
okay forget about that one I yeah you
know I actually I mean I don't know I
can't cuz like my dog pisses on the same
plant outside in front of the crib every
day and that plant is dead as [ __ ] but I
mean what is the rest of that plants
treatment plan what else is going on
with that plant your not monitoring that
plan yeah but all the plants around it
is doing fine it's just that plant but
that's the plant of my dog always pisses
on I mean here's the thing I've been to
your place Tony and your neighborhood is
in the midst of an opioid crisis so who
knows what's been dropped by that plant
man I like I like the way you worded
that you could have just said and
there's people shooting up on the corner
[Laughter]
ways yeah you know I have a great idea I
think you should get a green sleep mask
and that we should do an episode where
like we can do like yeah googly eyes
yeah like [ __ ] with your eyes mm-hmm so
like when you get it when you say
something while you get excited the eyes
get real wide and then like that would
be dope as [ __ ] actually I'll put just
different you know classic films classic
films going on like just pulp fiction's
playing on your face no face off face oh
that's very on the nose oh that's very
on the nose too oh oh that was a double
that was back-to-back bang bang bang
bang made me mad man
[Music]
[Music]
bat bat but that that that we need
that's one thing when people who do
start at that knock that I don't know I
find it out how do you even how do you
even google that that's a voice google
right google who'd made up that that
about that that that I think cousins is
that yes that's Boyle T's for that [ __ ]
nah public domain like the birthday song
bow down down then they don't don't go
don't don't don't
yeah yeah I think that's the birthday
song right yeah all right
it's December 30th today December 30th
almost 2019 yeah
goddamn it man it's actually 10 minutes
till New Year's Eve 10 minutes to New
Year's Day Hawaii at least is our Hawaii
sorry New Year's Eve yeah at the crib
I'm almost one year not drinking man
congratulations
January 2nd on January 2nd
obvi have one year that's crazy
no sauce I'm hyped about it I don't know
what I'm a I think I'm a what I'm gonna
do for a second stand in the water yeah
go uh maybe I wondered do I even want to
get drunk anymore no I think you should
keep it going
no I don't I don't really want to get
drunk anymore oh you wait you don't want
to get drunk no more no yeah but then
part of me was like what should I
celebrate a year by getting drunk is
seeing then I don't want to do it no
more well just keep it going
you should just go like balls out on
some ayahuasca oh no
oh no no ayahuasca no ayahuasca you
think you think you think Martin Luther
King ever did psychedelics no I don't
think so you don't got that yeah they
would have really jammed him up they
found out I think maybe Malcolm X might
uh I think he might have [ __ ] with
some acid you he got that you know he
kind of got that you know acid vibe that
rebellious you know you do acid and then
you're like damn the man type [ __ ] damn
so I could see him but not Martin Luther
can't use to religious for that stuff
super religious yeah and so I'm trying
to what sure what sure is 20:19
intentions and goals intentions and
goals yeah well I definitely want to get
back into shape
yeah well lose a little weight and I
want how much about seventy-five pounds
all right what's the action plan for
that just watch a lot of Bruce Lee
movies and do tons of push-ups
there's only push-ups yeah bad if I did
like think about it man think about this
if I did a thousand push-ups every day
yeah I'd be [ __ ] rip this [ __ ] in
like three months
absolutely that's what I'm saying [ __ ]
all this workout gym membership [ __ ] mmm
a thousand push-ups a day regular
push-ups or which you push up then clap
and then Matt whatever my body lets me
do at the one-handed [ __ ] flip over
maybe you know it but you do any tricep
dips I was something else no just push
up to balance the push up just push ups
a squats or no crunches no just pushes
push ups alright I'll just have a crazy
body all shoulders and chest but that
means I could do handstand push-ups - oh
and that's next level
okay so lot of push-ups no I'm just
playing no I mean I do like jail
workouts and [ __ ] I push up some
pull-ups right sit ups if you could do
if you could do a hundred each every day
I feel like you get in this shape pretty
well good Yeah right if you did a
hundred push-ups hundred situps
well not 100 pull-ups if you do 100
pull-ups you goddamn [ __ ] beast maybe
like if I get to at least 20 pull-ups
mm-hmm sonic crunches yeah yeah honey
squats in a hundred seconds running in
place
I don't need to do squats because I do
like kung-fu forms and stuff and it uses
a lot of leg muscles so when I do that
like that's more than enough leg work so
I don't need to do squats my apologies
to the squat family defense disrespect
it is that the opinion said on here did
not reflect the opinions of everybody so
yeah honey that's what I'm thinking for
yeah same thing what I want to try to
just in it even if I don't make it to
class or the gym do a honey honey honey
honey honey honey 100 club honey on it
every day and then see how that worked
we call it the wild hunted plan wild
honey playing honey
hood it crunches or the I have workout
honey
squats honey jumps jumping jacks
honey jumpers X and a honey sips of
water
honey sips of water and a hundred
seconds jogging in place hundred grams
of creatine and some amino acid from the
protein protein hundred laps around your
crib wherever you live no matter how
small the building do a hundred laps
around the edge of that because you need
cardiovascular work to but then it
depends on type of hundred jumping jacks
are you doing a jumping jacks jumping
jacks is easy yeah you know a song I've
been listening to that there's a
good workout song it's off of the creed
2 soundtrack I'll kill them with success
ok it's a super it's a hype workout song
yeah I listen to you I listen to like
podcast when I workout yeah
Siri play killing with six play killing
with success off the tree to soundtrack
we could probably just cut it in now I
want it I want the people to see my
struggles Siri play kill them with
success of the Creed 2 soundtrack well
that didn't work so that's a good goal
Tony lose 75 pounds now I mean obviously
I was exaggerating 95 pounds but man you
know get get Bruce Lee rip yeah I don't
think I could ever lose this gut though
like I was born with it and I've always
had it and I've worked out before to try
to get rid of it and done all kinds of
stuff and the gut the gut just won't go
I don't think that's good attitude
brother you know you know uh you know
how you can get that gut to go Wow stop
drinking that poison
stop drinking that boy
[Music]
Boylan
ringing boys
fumbling in man-boy
[Music]
yeah man that's how you do it
I can't give up the potion you gotta
give up the posting and that cut the gut
out can't give a potion man like I got
to figure out a plan where I could count
the calories and make up for it because
I just can't I can't give up like
tonight I cooked up that nice steak yeah
what a nice cab SAP next to it got the
potion got emotions called wine I like
to find time yeah but you know yeah
that's classically good hot dog no
ketchup just rusted you bastard that's
how we eat it we yeah you gave me
ketchup and I'll beat your [ __ ] face
that's how I'll do it I ain't race I got
emotions I got the potion it's called
wine I like the fine time
hello Portillo's give me Italian beef
with the hot and sweet peppers well I'm
a goose leper well that's right that's
right
swim classic classic lyric of yours but
you don't have to you don't have to live
the stuff do I change my lyrics man I'm
broke you change people change
talk about doing [ __ ] not do it I fire
up my [ __ ] son I remember you know good
bun meat bun beat he made pregnant [ __ ]
that's true and then he does he looks
back on that said what was I doing it
could be like you with the wine oh man I
rep that life man I used to pop that
life you know I had songs when I talk
about just my old life with the with the
drinking and the partying in and the
hopping out of taxicabs without paying I
don't do that anymore oh and I'm sorry I
hopped out without paying I thought it
was an uber
confused so uh my uh my thing for 2019
your thing well I'm filming my special
mm-hmm February 2nd so I think that's a
good date too cuz just cuz you stay on
your [ __ ] for the month of January so
it's good that do something yeah early
February so yeah I'm a really get into
it getting in shape I've been alright on
it but I didn't haven't been thoroughly
consistent all the time about to do some
boot camp [ __ ] huh about to just really
get after it and just you know do 200
hundred try to do a few yoga classes a
week do some do a couple cycling classes
a week maybe couple boxing do some I
want to get I want to be in great
physical shape I want my pacing from
side of the stage to side of the stage I
wanted to be very fluid
I might take two adult gymnastics
classes I'm up in two nastas classes
which bastards and I asked that that you
don't look at me differently because of
me not being able to see in the
gymnastics class man just help me to the
trampoline
[Music]
as it okay all right I thought you
sounded like you're about to go in I did
I just didn't want to you know I wanna
you know you're supposed to leave the
one at war and I feel like III hit the
peak and I could have kept going but I
didn't want to stretch out the premise
to the premise too much you got the mask
on so you're automatically on blackout
mode you should just be ready like
blackout every time every time you got a
pace this out you can't go full-speed
every time you're not I mean a fighter a
prizefighter don't just go crazy every
round you might go crazy round two round
one round three but then around four
five six
he chill a little bit concerned some
energy around seven round eight he might
diarrhea a little bit because he's
nervous and it's a huge crowd Dan nights
around ten nine eleven and then he bring
it back you know that if it's a dogfight
they just go at it and that talking
about dogs and they don't dogs on x12
round fights no they just go out these
off jump wait fight yeah is this you on
the record supporting dogfighting no I
was just saying is that what you're
doing right now are you I've never
okay oh yes PC a cello no need to say
listen don't worry I'm gonna edit this
out cuz I can't be next to you I'm like
why you said no I can't even I'm not
even gonna risk it I can't even be a
part of this try to take me down
Hannibal supports a dogfighting legend
now and then I find out Tony been doing
underground dogfights yeah on Big Island
and Kauai that's why it really took the
gig I'll be I'll be already there I can
check in on my stuff checking in over
there Kauai my dogfights anything be
good how about that for your 2019
resolution no more dog [ __ ] it out
the dog fighting game you talking about
push-ups and [ __ ] stop being a felon how
about you stop being a felon
what's way 19 be a better person my
other one is I want to start practicing
an instrument oh yeah yeah you want to
get into like musical theory I want to
play drums okay but do you want it like
are you trying to just hit drums or are
you trying to like learn I want three
drums I want to get very into it I
talked about like numbers like you know
like oh this is a three free to music or
[ __ ] no like just no one like the timing
and all that like this is a 5/4 beat
this is you know three four what a
sickness accounts rhythm that's innate
because I'm a musical genius okay yeah
all right I just want I just need to
learn just get my wrist loose really I'm
a natural but I just need to get the
muscle memory going you know because
most beats you know are like four four
eight ages but then when you start
[ __ ] with [ __ ] like 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
that's when things get weird that was
like can you get down with that that was
as far as class goes I'll I didn't
progress there most pop music is like
woah 1 you know sing along so I know it
cuz then what give me a familiar song so
I know it I'll beat that [ __ ] with a
bat I'll beat that [ __ ] with a bat
that's like a 4 4 8 so I don't do a Juke
song that's right but that's classic
like a house is classic but that's like
give a pop song that follows
songs too easy I say won't you come
around here it's Michael Jackson yeah
yeah well I was I wasn't you know I
wasn't here but you know I thought you
would get it off of the melody yeah so
yeah I'm take a drum and class like and
you learn a language but I bet I got
this app duolingo on my phone I'm a
child learning Spanish as fast as I
can't what a kind of speed through
Spanish in a couple months hopefully and
then get into the Chinese try why
Chinese
cuz they bout to run everything and I
want to be able to communicate with them
and I think but I think because I have
tiny eyes if I talk to the right person
that might have seen tag I could
convince them to let me in on their
deals and I can invest right behind them
just a little bit you know a little
fraction of what they invest I can throw
in a few stacks and just build with them
so I feel like learning a language what
really helped me get past that barrier
let's get your logic straight here so
because you have slanty eyes asking that
you is a slanty a slanting thank you for
being a said tiny yes okay so you should
learn the language right because you're
slanting eyes notice now what I said and
you've been a bad listener on purpose
okay I say okay I have tiny eyes yeah so
I might be able to pass phrasing or
Chinese or part Chinese so because of
that I
learn Chinese and then maybe somebody
there's a Chinese fan with some
influence in the countries investments
will help me get involved with those
investments but wait but which Chinese
you try to learn can't Cantonese or
Mandarin Mandarin because I like orange
juice don't you want to learn the type
that's more like business-minded
or is it just oranges you're going off
on oranges like it's one I like Mandarin
wait just so that's the one I didn't
know that way so one is more business
and one is more yes because like yo
there's there's northern China and
southern China okay so whatever party
you're on where's the most business
going down that's probably the one that
you want to learn this man it's a
billion come on man if I learn Mandarin
obviated find a plug I won't just be out
of the entire loop tell me no
businesspeople to speak Mandarin they're
very out of billions
they're very you'll be surprised a very
different man Mandarin and Cantonese are
very different but I'm saying there'll
be some business people that speak
Mandarin if they're business people they
speak both they business people they
need to speak to a lot of people and
they speak English to the top business
people but I'll speak Chinese to show
that I'm making the effort
so drums Chinese Spanish work out more
and a pet I think you should get a pet
and
yeah man it's time for you to have a to
be responsible for another life without
having a child I get like get like an
iguana or something
no pet thing in no pet I ain't get no
pet so I ain't no ain't get no cuz I'll
be travel that ok have no pet
I travel it no rappers wait a pet inside
the box I know iguanas no fish no
Darla's no cats no hamsters no llamas no
rats
I ain't getting no pet I ain't kidding
no pet no no no no and get no monkeys
nor an arsonist no for ringo's no psych
office and get no pets don't call the
cops I can't get no pets
yeah no $5,000 trips to the vet and get
no pets no Tweety birds no times Jerry's
nope nope nope no Animaniacs no no no
thank you no pets no Buffalo no don't
know cheetahs no no no birds no no no
hyenas ain't getting no pets and get no
pets no pets ain't getting no pets no
pets no pets I can't get no pest that
was hot man yeah it was until spazzed
out at the ends off your energy man I
was still go I was like that was very
jarring to as a visually impaired person
kind of in the pocket just in the pocket
of Ivan you know now really seeing
anything and then that was mine you just
decide the songs over Wow Wow
great great collaborative energy there
Jesus Christ I take it back Stevie
Wonder isn't overrated as I imagine as
blind person trying to get people on
your wavelength musically we can't make
eye contact keep that's it going he's
got to keep doing he that's why that's
why it does the hats why it does that
yeah can you like move others keep
making duck stay on the harmonica I love
other that's how you do it yeah well you
got to do that and I find them when you
nah man why not give me give me
something like swing your hand around or
something no just on the drums never
move is never to move when I fade out
lightly why not like just sort of faded
out and then if I stopped and I stopped
or if I keep rapping you could bring it
back in but going that's like I just
wanted you to scream that's not maybe
scream yeah like get primal you know you
know you don't want to make hit stop
this is you can't make hits that already
was a hit man no you want me it's me
then I broke down when you blind and
angry you get really angry because I
kind of anger you just you know you'll
get to like look off and distract
yourself or even you look at your phones
it with Church but you just kind of sit
I guess you do hop on the phone like yo
this will [ __ ] can you believe it but
the even that unit isn't you gotta just
stay with you yeah you can't like look
it off you gotta kind of district so
this mu oh man I'm sorry that I guess it
would have been different if you see
see then that feel good do you feel
better now
you feel a little bit better I know you
feel a little better so yeah I want to
get a say for the special languages
music and then yeah just more reading
more to on do more audiobooks maybe an
audiobook a week [ __ ] audiobook how do
you folks would know I'm not gonna say
that cuz we might get like audiobook
sponsors or some [ __ ] doesn't it be what
why is it I don't know people that
listen to podcasts audiobooks I feel
like they're in the same world you don't
understand so I'm not gonna talk [ __ ] I
just don't like audiobooks man I like
reading and I don't even like that
[ __ ] PDF [ __ ] eBook [ __ ] I like
paper books I like paper books too but I
like an audio book just cuz uh you can
kind of put it on before you go to sleep
and then if I fall asleep if you fall
asleep mm not as myseif in your brain uh
brain is a advanced computer it can
absorb you can absorb now is why you
sleep and then you know situation pop up
you think you don't know that then pop
up and then you spouting off facts 1977
that's when that happened oh yeah oh
yeah fell asleep fell asleep with Bernie
Mac's book on yeah I've been I'm so I'm
gonna do like maybe one audio book a
week wait and then one regular book
every two weeks and and then there's and
then start back drinking in March now
you don't mean that
you don't mean that right now you don't
mean Star Trek that yeah in March though
I like the sober animal well things
about to change brother about the spiral
oh yeah South by Southwest that's the
plan
oh I'll just have one
I'll just have one it's gonna be fine
everybody I'll just have one fast for it
I want to have later wobble wobble you
know what I got wallet like that dog dog
walk on the dance floor joking each
other that said that said I said it
shirt off shirt off just
see hand signals they helped they worked
[Laughter]
shut off on a dance floor
yelling drunk sweaty surrounded by
Millennials taking snapchat videos of me
doing a dark moment I can see the cover
a vulture Meg the next day and Wilbur's
naked at South by Southwest we thought
he was sober I mean if you're gonna get
back on the alcohol you better be
careful because that your tolerance is
not you gonna be drinking I mean that's
like oh yeah yeah yeah man you gotta
start with like like it like half like
quarter pours and work up you can't just
go right into the [ __ ] got to have
Jameson with a splash of ginger you
can't do that no I'm gonna get it going
slow I'm going to Dominican Republic oh
waa waa waa waa waa waa waa waa waa waa
what what
I still support sober wha-wha-wha
wha-wha-wha wha-wha-wha-wha and so yeah
that's the that's the three-month plan
short-term what's long term for 2019
2019 like what has to be done before
2020 comes around well I want to go to
one of those laboratories it's are you
pooping so drinkable water okay and I
want to do that with my poop why is that
a long-term can't you just do that
tomorrow
no why not is that is the technology not
there yet
no tomorrow's a holiday okay so why
can't you do that like next week
I got gigs but that's just something
like all you got to do is [ __ ] and put
it in the bag and send it somewhere
right are you saying that you want to do
it yourself
are you saying that you want your [ __ ]
to be turned into consumable water I
wanted to return is awarded by somebody
else right yes so why can't you just
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] ziplock bag and send
it out that's not you can't just be
sending your [ __ ] that's a threat if
it's not it's like I'm not saying it's
like a hazardous waste
but can't you end it can't you hit up
like a spot and go after I want to it
you have to do it in purpose and you
have to do it in person and it's
appointment only
and they've backed up for months so
that's why it's the end of the year
thing and they don't care about my movie
career so I can't skip the line and I
respect that process so maybe that's
happening in November maybe the lines
not backed up and the people in line are
backed up all right dad sorry my bad I
just had to put that was there yeah
you know sometimes I wish I wish I
could've saw the light in your eye right
before you say ah you'll see it there
was a glow out like I like I like I like
that I that that I die that's kind of
it's uh it's funny Drake just talk about
even half a xanax bar just leave it on a
flight yeah
but I guess the production is so dope
about that too you know what I'm glad
that you brought that up because I
thought about that I'm like that's
literally probably the most boringest
[ __ ] that you could talk about in a rap
song like I ate something that puts me
to sleep and I fell asleep on an
airplane
now as to a light like a light and he
repeats it like a light like I get it
you ate a sleeping pill went to sleep on
a plane like that's not that's not that
exciting it's that's them like literally
the most boring [ __ ] he's more excited
to be like I was on the plane I was on a
long guy's flight and then I went to
coach and went up to everybody's like
gave them high five I'm Drake I would
have to everybody said I'm Drake and I
gave him high five then we got real I
woke up sleeping people that's it yeah
no I like that song but that part I
always questioned that part like I don't
I'm like why are you talking that's just
relatable no that's maybe that's the
thing is then no because most rappers
talk about saying like it's a party drug
which I still don't understand and then
he's talking about zan like how it
actually works it just puts you to sleep
so he's talking about like the the real
real affection so maybe he's trying to
just change the narrative about xanax
and you know what push it in a more
reasonable you know what if that
direction I got a lot of respect for
Drake all of a sudden because that's
what I do if I ever take when I take
xanax it's like oh I gotta go to bed
and I'm feeling a little amped and
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on in my
head right I'm gonna pop this Zen so
drain slows down go to sleep I was like
a light right yeah so maybe yeah he's
trying to just show responsible use
because he said half of a Zen that's one
cause he knows how strong it is and just
a half that's right good for you man
tell the kids tell the kids all you need
is a half for a 14-hour flight I know
that's what I took to Korea I took half
of one were you out like a light I was
out our out like a man that yells in his
sleep yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's me and I'm yelling in my sleep
give me a drink but I'll sleep dude you
give me the drink when I'm yelling in my
sleep does she get a drink if I yell and
order in my sleep will she bring it to
me or will she think I'm sleep will she
look at my eyes and see that their eye
closed Oh was she bringing my drink
because I said it's so bring me my drink
even though I am sleep my eyes are
closed but I still can't think I'm
knocked out but I still am talking
seatbelt on so I'm not sleep walking
down the aisle
bring me my drink yeah I am sleep but I
might be up so just bring me that ginger
ale and ice in a cup what
[Music]
yes oh thanks Drake thanks for being
reasonable Drake shoutout
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up shoutouts to 20 20 18
stuff that you liked huh
what you like in 2018 2018 buy anything
what did you like what I like I like to
go on Africa okay that was fun
West Africa and East Africa Nigeria
Lagos we should get into your Africa
experience like deeply on another
episode we will we have some you have
you got some good stories I had two
stories two stories they true stories
they Gentile and a few stories hmm what
else did I like what did you like in
2018 I like the films any good films I
didn't see as many movies as a TV show I
never see as many movies as I feel like
I guess in my head I have this idea that
I should be watching for movies week in
the theater but then I remember that I
don't like acting so I don't need to you
know watch that many for research I saw
that did you see that Bohemian Rhapsody
I didn't you didn't I didn't I wasn't
that good bro I don't know wasn't that
good Rolling Stones critic Chris Travers
said it was a riot and an emotional
rollercoaster
so he's tripping and also huh Ain't It
Cool News said it was wow that was just
a review Wow well Toni trim says she was
kind of wack
I I don't know a you were you of hmm I
mean I could get into it but you know
how I get about ranting about films well
he mere after the that's the that's the
that's a Don Rickles story right yeah
yeah yeah there's about Don Rickles in
that song that he wrote Bohemian
Rhapsody the Galileo yeah yeah it was a
bit in a song nice rest appease Don
Rickles
he stayed working pretty free late he
was loved it he was still working in his
ninety still touring a little bit what
and is what we know what how wait what
wait wait wait wait Don Rickles was
torrent and it Don Rickles was in his
90s you said Don Rickles probably had
tour dates on the books when he died 90
how wait how old was he when he died I
think he was actually 90 okay that's a
Siri okay this is gonna take like 15
minutes you want me to just no no no no
I got it
don't don't treat me like a charity case
tonight don't treat me like a dirty
cries hey Syria no drums
I need see we can't hear the drums yes
you can
unless you can't cuz you got headphones
on oh she can you maybe hear through the
headphones headphones left stop real
quick I'm still distracting hey dude how
old was Don Rickles when he died he may
be saying it on my screen your [ __ ] is
just ripping it just says I'm listening
just keep saying I'm listening I don't
know Siri how old was Don Rickles when
he died
sixth 2017 at age 19 I knew you were
right on yeah so he was working no he
was yeah that's crazy
uh what about wasn't Rodney Dangerfield
working late too as a old man cuz I
remember him being nothing he didn't get
how was right I think Rodney died didn't
70s his 70s Dangerfield yeah yeah do it
again
who did you like better as a comic Don
Rickles or Rodney Dangerfield uh I'd say
yes sirree how old was riding
Dangerfield when he died 882 so he was
up there too man
yeah uh as a comic I mean I got to see
more of Rickles you know yeah because
you still doing roasts and popping up on
talk shows and [ __ ] he was still doing
hella appearances but wasn't riding he
liked it more in more movies with me
more like a movie movie guy than a comic
he did a couple movies but he was on
ladies planet no I didn't see lady was
he plays a soccer coach but it's a
female soccer team so he's got to be a
lady coach it's pretty oh it's pretty
funny it's like mrs. Doubtfire yes
soccer it's good it's a classic isn't
yeah it's not good but it's it's funny
cuz it's Rodney Dangerfield
it's a it's a classic for me but I like
movies dumb movies like that okay you
know so so what you're saying is that I
shouldn't trust your opinion about
Bohemian Rhapsody no no you should trust
my opinion about cuz well actually
actually actually okay I'm a big Queen
fan you know I'm really into that bad
yeah
and so like I know the history of the
bad really well and then I felt like the
movie just didn't do the band justice
yeah and like I think I think they were
like they were - they didn't know
whether they were making a movie about
Freddie Mercury or the ban or that
goddamn song right so it's like okay
make a movie about one one of those
things but you can't condense all three
of those things into one [ __ ] movie
you just can't like that should have
been like a [ __ ] goddamn three season
[ __ ] TV show I got it watch it you
talking to me like I watched it you know
what I'm saying yeah and so you kind of
you kind of are putting your opinion you
like kind of trying to poison my
perspective and you know I I can't have
it because you just pitched me a
cross-dressing soccer coach movie but I
didn't go into ladybugs thinking like yo
man I'm really in the soccer and women's
soccer team teenage women's soccer teams
with a good coach I don't know nothing
about soccer I just like Dangerfield and
in the flick and it was good right it
was goofy like that I didn't go in with
any expectations but you're rating a bio
you're doing a biopic about a very
influential rock band you got it you got
it you got it you gotta you gotta go
it's got to be really good and it's
gonna be probably super a lot like yeah
I feel I feel bad like I'm not gonna
even like knock on it because it's just
I feel like they just the Hollywood
probably just didn't give him give him
enough time to like to really justify
what you know the band so Queen that's
uh welcome to the jungle right
no that's guns from roses no Queen we
will rock you we are the champions
laying claim did they did pour some
sugar right no
okay Queen you just think you're just
naming all the hair hair metal bands now
wait so clean we are the champions my
friends Queen did how soon is now okay
that's a that's a cut if that's if I
don't know that's a cut then I don't
know Queen oh okay I mean but that's
like the big song you know everybody
knows the the Queen they did play that
funky music white boy damn not you just
[ __ ] around
I was around the whole time yeah you
know what my favorite my favorite Queen
song was probably the one the joint they
did with David Bowie that Vanilla Ice
sampled for Ice Ice Baby
yeah then the doom that our doom doom
yeah that's a hell bass line though you
gotta admit that's a boy that's a pretty
heavy bass line Oh
show's over
the cells over Oh in the show do you
just mess yourself in the show you know
the show you must cut the cameras cut
the cameras
are we done we're done
[Music]
[Music]